right by the border the South Korean
national team of their base in paju here
the South Korean coaches are getting
their pro license their German
instructor ethical Tamela has bags of
experienced player here and crossing Oh
dribbling crossing what is the
difference but it's not just tactics and
drills who Tamela works on the
psychological side of the game as well
but well I don't see the 4 line
difference isn't newer members I'm
exaggerating a bit but they're used to
being obedient and that can inhibit
creativity you won't achieve innovation
in the game that way you know what tifa
storm field and route some other
challenges the students to be creative
cog abandon go to manipulative he
teaches us how to think about football
not just details but tactics he makes us
think gets us to solve problems and that
helps us k so Molly told me didn't get
it before he was an instructor he
coached Bundesliga sides hansa rostock
and cologne and then joined the German
coaching staff a 98 world cup then he
was chief instructor at the german
football association bruno Livadia and
Mehmet Scholl were under his tutelage
route amala has worked all over the
world he's trained north and south
koreans the three it's yeah neither
fellas wish to inform our standing here
at the border between North and South
Korea especially as a German it makes
you think about reunification yeah admit
for AI nua when I'm here I get the
feeling that things can work out again
in the future just cannot married a
plumber's Muslim go north korea's or a
unification jessica place already ruh
Tamela is a german football ambassador